[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAMOUN HIRZALLA: My
name is Mamoun Hirzalla.
I'm a principal Cloud
Architect with Accenture.
I'm part of the Google Center
of Excellence within Accenture,
where our mission is primarily
to help clients adopt
the Google Cloud, and
use the right components,
and architect the right
solutions for them.
My partner for this
presentation apologizes.
And he had to be at
the client setting.
So I would be doing
the session alone.
So before I go into
the session and talk
about what we're
going to cover, let
me just do a quick poll here.
How many in the session
migrated some of their data,
or all of their data, to
Google Cloud or any cloud?
Great, about 20 people.
And how many of
those, or others,
have applied machine
learning to that data?
A few-- six, seven of them.
OK, great-- anybody
not interested in data?
OK, good.
Just checking.
So in today's session, basically
what I'm going to cover
is talk about some of the
data migration challenges
that we see in the field.
We talk to a lot of customers,
and every customer situation
is unique.
And every customer brings to
the table a set of challenges
that they may
inherit or encounter
depending on their situation.
And we have seen many of those.
So we will be sharing some
of those challenges with you,
and talk about
how we can address
these type of challenges.
So that will be the first
part of the presentation.
And then we'll look into more
specific GCP-type of constructs
from data perspective
that would help
as part of the
migration of your data
from on-prem type of situations
or other cloud providers
to Google Cloud Platform.
And then we'll look at
some of the architectures
or best practices
that would lead
you to get your data into
GCP, and then talk briefly
about machine learning,
and some of the use
cases for machine learning,
and what can you do about that.
And then I'll cap it off
with a client example
that we have worked
with, to migrate
their existing on-prem Hadoop
infrastructure to Google Cloud
Platform, and talk about some
of the aspects of that example,
and some of the lessons learned
that we can share with you.
And I'm sure a lot
of you probably
are thinking or doing
some of that work
as part of the process.
So let's talk about the
migration challenges.
And before I get
into the challenges,
anybody knows what that is?
Swamp, correct.
And the swamp here
pictured is very
expressing to some
of the challenges
that we're seeing
with our customers.
People started looking
into Hadoop, probably
around 2008, 2009,
and started migrating
some of their existing
data to Hadoop.
And lots of hype happened
when it comes to Hadoop.
And a lot of customers
ended up with lots of data
being migrated to
Hadoop, whether that's
needed or not needed, the
right solution or not,
it doesn't matter.
In IT, we look for these
type of new technologies,
and we start hyping them.
And suddenly, we think that
is the right answer for many
of the problems that we have.
So a data lake that's supposed
to be nice, clear, pristine,
that allows you
to get and gather
the right insights from the
data that you have turns out
to be a data swamp,
because of the fact
that the insight that was
promised when the data was
started to be migrated
is not being fulfilled,
along with the fact that the
performance and the issues
around maintenance
and, the expenses
that are associated
with data lakes
are spiraling out of control.
And that basically
puts a bucket of water,
if you will, cold water
on the whole process.
And people start
becoming less trusting
of these type of
hype-type of technologies,
and it impacts the
whole organization.
So this diagram basically
shows a heart, not necessarily
a broken one, in case you
think that it is the case.
It's just a heart.
And that heart represents the
vitality of your organization.
That vitality basically
comes from a variety
of type of factors.
You can look at
your infrastructure
as one factor of that vitality.
You can look at
your platforms that
are based on that type
of infrastructure,
and you can look at your
applications that are basically
being built on top of that.
What we're seeing being built
today, these type of things,
they're great.
We can do a great job on
these type of systems.
But we're seeing
missing in the field
that the data is the
missing link when it comes
to these types of systems.
We have data.
But we don't have the right
set-up, the right quality.
We cannot get the right
insights out of that data.
So that becomes a challenge,
and that basically
contributes to the
fact that you are not
realizing the full
potential of the data
as part of the process.
Now, some of these
challenges that we
have when it comes to data--
and I think probably all
of you would relate to it--
data silos.
Anybody who has never
encountered any type of data
silos within the organization,
I would love to meet them.
So data silos is a common
problem, and even with Hadoop.
When people started
building data lakes,
the premise was you
have a data lake
so that you dump all the
data in one single lake.
Then when you go and
talk to customers,
you start looking at somebody
has Cloudera somewhere.
They have MapR somewhere.
They have other type of
distributions in data lakes.
And the question that
basically needs to be asked,
why is that happening?
And that's part of
the other symptom
that we're having, because
of the fact that the data
is growing at
significant type of rate.
And that significant
type of rate
basically is forcing you
to look at it and say,
well, there has to be
something good out of it,
and I need to
store it somewhere.
And you start adding
and adding and adding.
And that becomes a
problem in itself.
And the questions
that should have
been asked when you start adding
this data type of attributes
and these data volumes should
have been asked in terms of,
well, is that the right
data that I need to look at?
Is it in the right format?
Are we going to use that data?
Do I need to go and store
it in its existing format?
Or do I need to
manipulate it before I go
and get it into my data lake.
These questions, in
many of our customers
where they have these
type of situations,
are not being asked.
And that's part of
the problem that's
being manifested by the fact
that I have a data lake,
but I'm not fulfilling the
promise of that data lake.
And can you please
come and help us look
into what we can do about it.
So these are a type
of common challenges
that we see with our customers.
And many times,
when customers start
with these type of things,
they start looking into a POC.
In a POC type of setting,
everything is great.
You take a simple use case.
You create a POC.
You run successfully
with it, and you say, OK,
well let's continue with that.
That's not the right answer.
A POC is a point in time, small
snapshot that basically needs
to be taken with
a grain of salt.
When you're done
with that POC, there
has to be some type
of expansion into what
does it mean when it
goes into production,
and what type of extra
additional steps or corners
that you have cut in order to
make a timeline for that POC,
and achieve that success
criteria that you agreed upon
before you started that POC.
Oftentimes, you
constrict the scope
so that you can do this
in four weeks, six weeks.
Everybody feels
excited about it.
Then that continues to be
part of the organization.
And then that's where the
problem starts spiraling up.
And then the fact that we
have lots and lots of data
explosions, and the fact that
if you look at the database
vendors five, seven
years ago, there
used to be the typical
four or five vendors.
And it was a very easy
selection between A and B and C
companies.
Now if you look at the
diagram, you'll probably
see 50, 60, 70 type of vendors.
Everybody is vying for the
best in XYZ different type
of structures coming up.
Lots of companies are basically
having issues and doubts
understanding what does it mean
to be in this type of format
or that type of format.
So that's part of what's
contributing to the mix,
as well, and the fact that we
have lots of skills issues that
are hard, basically, for
everybody to keep up with,
because the change of the
technology is so significant.
And I'm sure many of
you in this session
are suffering from that.
You just can't keep up.
You have to be aware
of lots of things
in order to keep up
with the pace of change.
And if that's part
of your situation,
then it becomes a problem
for the organization where
you don't have the right skills
to make the right decisions.
And compound that
with additional type
of different, complex
type of platforms where
you need to be in
different type of settings
with hybrid different platforms.
That makes it even harder.
So these are some
of the challenges
that we're seeing in the field.
And to look at these
challenges, and not
to do anything
about them would be
something that would set you up
for even failure down the road.
Now what's our approach
for data migration
in Accenture or general?
And before I go and address
the data migration approach,
let me just talk
about three factors,
or reminders to remind
ourselves before we
get into the approach.
The first one is, remember
always the objective.
State the objective, and try to
measure against that objective.
That will help you
down the road when
you assess whether what you
have done is correct or wrong.
If your objective was I
am building this project,
whether it's Hadoop
infrastructure
on-prem or on-cloud or
machine learning, you name it.
My objective is
ABC, and here's how
I'm going to measure
that objective.
And here are the metrics that
I'm going to measure about.
Because if you don't put
these type of things,
there is no guarantee
that when you finish
at the end of the day when,
the CIO or the CTO comes to you
and says, how are we
doing on this, well,
we didn't set an objective,
therefore everything will go.
But if you set
certain objectives,
you have to report against
these type of objectives.
And it keeps you honest as
well as part of the process.
So it's part of
the self-governance
that you need to instill as
part of the organization,
and starts with that.
And as part of the
process, remember
that we want to derive
value out of data
to enable ubiquitous
type of intelligence,
what we call in Accenture.
Different companies call
it different things.
But we want to have that type
of intelligence, insights
that we want to
bring to the table.
And we want to make
sure that we are
bound by these type of
objectives and goals
as part of the process.
And as you go and
try to accomplish
that type of objective,
which is a very noble one,
there are different
types of companies.
We know that different
type of customers
have different type of settings.
And what's appropriate
for a small business
may not be appropriate
for a large enterprise.
So you would have to take
that with my company, five
people company, 10 people,
or 100, or 1,000, or 20,000,
with 2,000 people in IT--
different skills
mean different things
how you can accomplish or go
about what type of approach
that you want to take when
it comes to data migration.
And if you were to look at
it, the way we look at it
at Accenture, we have a
maturity scale, if you will,
where it's incremental.
So customers look at it
and start looking at, well,
one of the first things that
we do, we look at data storage
type of migrating to the cloud.
That's one of the
easiest things that
will get your feet wet as
part of the process, where
you can start migrating
some of these type of things
to the cloud.
As you start getting
them into the cloud,
you start looking at
your applications.
What can I do within my
application type of domain
so that I can leverage
this data that I have just
migrated to the cloud?
As you start looking
into that, you
start looking for ways to
optimize your data architecture
for new, different
type of applications
that you basically say,
I no longer like the fact
that we're bound by these
type of legacy constraints
that we had earlier.
So we're trying to
re-architect systems
that leverage
everything on the cloud.
That's what we call
born-on-the-cloud type
of things, or native type
of cloud applications.
And as you start gaining the
lessons learned and experience,
our objective is, at
the end of the day--
and it's an incremental one,
just let me emphasize that--
is to get to what
we call the "data
intelligence" on the
cloud, whether that
means machine learning, AI, or
whatever it is, you name it.
It doesn't matter.
I want to extract that
insight from the cloud
so that I have the
right consumers,
I have the right insights
at my fingertips.
And that would allow me
to impact the business,
so that I can operate using
new, different business models,
new revenue streams.
Because I'm able to consider
new patterns that my data is
allowing me to do.
And that intelligence is
giving me insight such
that I can go and
start marketing
to a different segment
that I completely
ignored before using that
type of intelligence,
or before using
machine learning.
New different
clusters of customers
are coming up, a new way of
discovering new medicines
or interactions between
different medical type
of components.
So all of these type of
things, the objective
is to get to that data
supply chain on the cloud
so that we re-architect
our on-prem type of data
so that it's modernized
and extended to the cloud.
And at the end of
the day, I can create
these type of services that
would allow me to go there.
And as part of that
process, basically, you
have to go and look at what
can I do differently to get
to that level of maturity.
So it all starts with capturing.
So we have different type
of formats, different type
of data that's
coming along the way
from different type of sources.
Is your existing
type of practices
capable of capturing
that type of data?
And most likely,
the answer is not.
So you have to go
out and look at that,
and assess what's needed
in order to get there.
Once you capture, curate.
Put that with 10
underlines there,
because that's one of the
premises that would guarantee
you that you will not
fall into that data
swamp type of practice.
It's one of them,
but it's the key one.
When you start curating
your data, that
means basically not a single
person will come and say,
we'll just get that file and
dump it into the data lake.
There would have to be
lots of checks and balances
that basically would say,
why are you doing that?
What type of data that
we're getting into?
What type of data profiling
that needs to be applied?
What type of metadata,
et cetera, et cetera.
That needs to get there.
And once you do
that, I can enable
the consumption of that data
in my type of organization.
And then I enable
additional things
related to manage and govern.
Because once you get it
there, you need to manage it.
You need to govern it.
And that becomes a
continuous cycle.
And then as new things
happen, you need to evolve.
You don't just do
it once and say,
I'm done with it,
because there is always
a new data format
that would come up,
that may expedite things,
that may do 10x load
factor for your data,
that could be something
that you want to look into.
And then how you can
operate that data,
and get it into the new
ways of doing things,
whether that's
social, mobile, IoT,
whatever it is that we hear
about all this time as part
of the evolving of technology
that we see on a daily basis.
Now, this slide is not
intended to scare you,
especially for those who are
on the small and medium size.
This slide is
really here to show
the level of sophistication
and complexity
that is required in order to
get to the right data practices.
Why is that?
Because it's not an Accenture
invention if you look at it.
I mean, it starts all the
way from vision, and mission,
and creating the right data
strategy for your organization,
all the way down to what
type of measurements,
and then the cross-cutting
concerns around governance
management.
If you are an SI sitting in this
room, you come and say, well,
we have something similar.
And I'm sure a lot of you
are doing something similar
to that.
And I raise it here just
because it's needed.
Whether you implement
100% of that
or you implement 50%
of that, or whatever
percentage that you think is
appropriate for your business,
remember the three principles
we talked about earlier.
I have an objective.
I have a different
way to approach it,
whether I'm small and medium
versus a large organization.
And similarly, I look at
this type of methodology
and say, what do I need
to take out of that?
And that becomes a decision
point for your organization,
so that you look at it, and
say, for my organization,
I'm going to do these
type of activities,
or I'm going to do some of them,
and I'm skipping X, Y, and Z.
And you document that.
And there should be
a good, valid reason
why aren't you doing that.
So that becomes an important
thing so that you are aware,
at least you give it a thought,
for my type of situation,
I don't need that.
And here is looking at
it from an agnostic type
of perspective.
You start looking at your
data sources, data staging,
data ingestion, how you are
going to curate the data.
All of these type of
things are decision points.
What are you doing about that
type of real-time ingestion
for this type of data formats?
Are you having to deal
with that type of setup,
or is that something
that's not necessary?
And if you do have
this type of thing
and you're not doing
anything about it,
are you losing any type
of benefits as a business
from not paying enough
attention to that type of data?
So let me switch gears
to data migration to GCP.
And I think that's where
the majority of you
are coming here as
part of the process.
So we covered the methodology.
And the key point
from the methodology
is the fact that it's not
a trivial type of endeavor.
If you talk to
somebody, and I have
talked to many customers in the
past, where they come to us--
we'll just move
that data from here
to Google Cloud in 10
minutes or one hour.
That's it.
That is the wrong answer.
Yes, we can do that.
But is that what we want?
The answer is no.
And for the previous
reasons, if that
has planted the seeds of doubt,
when somebody comes talks
to you about this
type of proposition,
I think you need to be asking
these types of questions
when somebody
comes and says it's
an hour type of job, or
two hours, or three days,
or whatever it is.
Because the objective is not
to get the data to the cloud.
The objective is what can
I do with that data, what
type of insight, what
type of governance
that needs to be there.
So let's keep that in mind as
we look into data migration
to GCP, because I'm going
to be claiming that it's
going to take 10 minutes.
Because yes, it does.
But keep that in mind.
So the first question when
it comes to data to GCP
is the question around
speed of network
and how much data do you
have as part of the process.
So if you're trying to migrate
10 terabytes or 100 terabytes
of data, and you're
having a network
speed of 100
megabits per second,
you can see that
for 10 terabytes,
I'm going to take 12 days.
For 10 megabits I'm
going to take 124 days.
If you happen to be on the
lucky side of 1 gigabyte, or 10
gigabyte, or 100, even, it's
going to take much less.
So the question you will
basically need to ask
is, am I going to do this
on a physical type of manner
versus online?
And you use this
chart, basically,
to help you to decide.
If you all happen to be
on this lower corner here,
most likely, you are going to
use a physical type of approach
to move your data from whatever
location into Google Cloud.
Next question that
comes to be asked,
and it's an important
question, is
if you were to look at
the Google data constructs
that we have out of GCP, if you
look at it for the first time,
it could be overwhelming.
So the next question that
basically you need to ask
is what type of data
I'm trying to migrate.
And if you start from
top, you can look at it
from two different
classifications.
Either it's structured
data or unstructured data.
If it's unstructured data,
it's pretty much easy.
If I don't have a need
for mobile as the case,
Google Cloud
Storage most likely,
an object type of storage,
will be the answer to you.
If you were to say, it's
more of a structured data,
than we look at it
from OLTP versus all
that type of classification.
If it has more of a
transactional load,
we have a decision point
that we need to make.
If it has more of
analytics type of load,
we have the Bigtable
versus BigQuery.
And the primary difference
is in the type of latency
that you get in terms of
Bigtable versus BigQuery.
If it's on the transactional
workload, then you look at it
and say, do I have a
preference for SQL type
of interfaces versus no SQL?
And that's where you look at
that and say, for SQL type,
we have the cloud SQL
with MySQL and Postgres
as the two flavors that you
get out of the box in GCP,
plus Cloud Data Spanner for
the horizontal scalability
and real-time type of
applications that require
that level of performance.
And for those who want to do
the newest SQL document type
of story, you have Cloud
Datastore and Firebase Realtime
DB, especially for needing
mobile SDKs you can use that,
but doesn't necessarily mean
that you cannot use Cloud
Datastore with mobile devices.
It just gives you
additional capabilities
when it comes to notifications
and these type of things,
that makes life a little
bit easier for you.
The third question
that you need to ask
is, I figured out it's going
to be physical or online.
I figured out what type of
construct that I need to get.
Then the third question is,
how can I get my data into GCP?
And that's what this slide
is trying to address here.
And look at it in
terms of distance
to GCP at the
bottom, the x-axis.
And the y-axis is
the amount of data.
So from x-axis perspective,
you look at it,
if you are GCS, or
Google Cloud Storage,
the data is already
there on Google Cloud.
Could be in a different region.
You want to shift it
to another region.
Or it could be in S3 Buckets,
Amazon, or something else.
Or it could be in a
colo type of facility
with good type of
connectivity, or on-prem
with that type of connectivity.
Or it could be somewhere on
premise with low bandwidth
or no bandwidth at all.
You have to see.
So what do you do with
these type of situations?
If you were to look at
it from that perspective,
we have the Google
Transfer Service that's
part of the Google Console.
So you can go to storage,
and you can set up
the Google Transfer Service.
You can do it run
once, run daily,
so you can think of it,
if you want to, as a cron
job that you can do
to backup continuously
as part of the process.
And there is no limit
on the amount of data
that you can do with the
Google Transfer Service.
It can do retries as well.
And it can help you
with that perspective.
If you were to look at the colo
type of situation or on-prem
with good connectivity,
then one of the primary
answers we have is gsutil.
You get gsutil as
part of the Cloud SDK.
You can install it, and
you can start gsutil CP.
And you can copy from
bucket to bucket,
or you can copy from
one location to another.
And it has the ability to shunt
the file into multiple ones,
and aggregates them on the end.
And it does all of that for you.
It has retries,
can do all of that.
If you don't like gsutil,
you have different vendors
that you can use also.
If you want an approach that a
vendor could come in and do it
for you, you can use
BitSpeed, Aspera, Tervela,
and there are other
vendors as well.
I put the link later
where you can go and look
at the latest and greatest.
Then the third
option, if you don't
have enough bandwidth
or no bandwidth at all,
so if the data size is
less than 100 terabytes,
usually you would get into the
Iron Mountain in North America.
And that is the prime
focus technologies
in EMEA and AsiaPac.
And you could still use the
Google Transfer Appliance.
So these are things
that you can do.
If the data size goes
above 100 terabytes,
you can have the Google
Transfer Appliance where they
ship that appliance to you.
You put the data, and then
ship it back to Google.
And they'll import it back
to you, the right project
to the right buckets in
Google Cloud Storage.
And the same thing for Zadara.
Zadara also has an
option for data hydration
where it ships two devices.
One you can put the
data and ship it back.
The other one you
can keep it on prem,
where it starts syncing the
data for delta type of changes
down the road.
Now this is pretty much
for the first entry
into Google Cloud practice,
Google Cloud Storage.
You may have structured data.
And structured data is also--
you can move it from
different types of sources
to different type of things.
And primarily for
structured data,
if you looked at the
previous diagram,
we have two databases
or two constructs.
One is the cloud SQL
with MySQL and Postgres.
And the other one is Spanner.
You can, if you want to, use
the old, traditional ways
of doing data dumps, compress
or dumps from SQL 1 to SQL 2.
And you can do that.
But lots of customers
don't want to do that.
They want to migrate
or move tons of data,
and they'd rather use a partner.
You can do that, too.
And you can do the same
thing for BigQuery.
It's also a partner
play, where you
can have different
type of sources coming
from databases, SaaS data
warehouses, or B2B EDI
type of stuff.
And you have all these
partners that are basically
having their different type of
solutions catering to migrating
that data to BigQuery.
And also, we have this that was
announced last year, that you
can migrate and the ability to
ingest data from DoubleClick,
the digital marketing
type of platform
from Google, along with
AdWords and YouTube.
And you have
additional sources that
are listed under that link
for Facebook, Twitter,
et cetera that can be part of
that process of migrating data
to BigQuery.
There are other people
who are on the other end
of the spectrum, where they
have the right engineering
or whatever it is.
They would like to
tinker with their hands.
And Google gives you
the ability to do that.
So you can use gsutil tool
do that if you want to.
So you can get the
data through gsutil
to a Google Cloud Storage.
And then you can use either
the bq command, if you want to,
or you can use
the web UI, or you
can use BigQuery APIs to
get the data into BigQuery.
It's just a more manual
approach that you would
have to be kind of doing that.
Just something to keep in mind--
bq tool, when you get
the data to BigQuery,
you're basically making a
fundamental assumption--
you are not enriching
the data or there's
very minimal type
of changes that you
need to do on the data.
The moment you start saying,
I want to do multiple joins,
I want to do some
data enrichment,
then that's where data flow
comes into the picture.
And I'll talk
about that shortly.
But that basically is what this
fundamental premise here-- you
can use user-defined
functions in BigQuery
to do certain manipulations.
But still, it's limited
in terms of the enrichment
that you can do on the data set
before moving it to BigQuery.
Now this slide--
I don't recommend that
you show that slide
to your customers or anybody
outside of being a techie,
because it's overwhelming,
to be honest with you.
If you, to show that,
hey, by the way,
I'm going here to sell
you something on Google.
And here's what Google
offers out of the table.
It's complete opposite purpose.
I just show it
here because I want
to show you there are
tons of capabilities.
And the objective is to
be more prescriptive when
you talk to your customers.
Yes, it's great that we
have a lot of constructs
around capture, curate,
discover, manage,
and consume and manage.
But you, as a potential
partner or customer,
you need to figure out what
is the right use case for you.
What is the right
construct for you?
And then try to figure out,
here's what I need to do.
It may be cloud data prep,
cloud data flow, cloud Pub/Sub,
and BigQuery.
So these are the ones
that I'm interested in.
The rest, it's great to have.
I can look into it later, but
to show that to your customers
from the get-go could
be counter-productive.
Now, there are customers who
basically say, you know what?
I don't like this whole
thing about the migration.
So I want a white-glove
type of service.
And that's where
Accenture comes in.
With every vendor, you
looked at the vendors
in the previous slides.
There are so many of them.
And with so many of
them, basically that
gives you the freedom
to choose, but also
gives you the potential that you
may shoot yourself in the foot,
because you may be picking
the wrong construct.
You may be picking the
wrong cloud platform.
You may be picking
the wrong tool.
And Accenture
basically allows you
to do in that white-glove type
of approach, with what we call
the "smart data
movement," you just
tell us, "We want to move
from point A to point B."
And you don't worry
about the rest.
We go and procure
these type of licenses
for the right tool for you.
And we do the migration.
And all you have
to do is just let
us see where the
data is coming from,
and where it needs to
go to, and that's it.
We take care of that.
So that's part of the contract.
And we also have capabilities
around different types
of elements when it comes to
capture, curate, discover,
consume, and manage.
So there are different
capabilities there.
I'm not going to go into
them, but just be aware
that they are available to you.
Here's the SDM type of
approach under the covers.
Basically, we cater
to a different type
of cloud providers.
GCP happens to be one of them.
Under the cover, the right
tools would be procured,
licenses managed for
you, and you get to that.
So you're pretty much agnostic.
You don't care
about whether it's
tool A, tool B, that vendor
goes out of business tomorrow
or are they still in business.
Doesn't matter.
We just give you the
guarantee that data be there.
You're not locked into
any specific vendor,
and that does the job for you.
So let's talk about path
to machine learning and AI.
So machine learning
and the use cases,
I doubt there has been
any session today where
machine learning probably
was not mentioned somewhere
in that session.
We are at that level
of hype cycle that--
and don't get me wrong.
I love machine learning.
I mean, I think it's a
wonderful technology.
But with everything else
like we have done in IT, when
we start looking at
something, and overhype it,
and we start looking it's
the answer to every question
that we have, that's where
the problems start arising.
And I think we are at that level
where everybody says, and comes
talk to us, I want to apply
machine learning to my X, Y, Z.
And I bet you that many of
those type of customers,
they don't have
the right awareness
on what is meant by
machine learning,
and if that is the right
set of tools or processes
that would allow them
to address the problem.
But as you can see, there
are lots of use cases
that are listed here across
different type of industries,
that basically
everybody is looking
at saying, predictive
maintenance or condition
monitoring.
We've done that with
predictive model in the past.
Things were OK, probably
80%, 90% accuracy.
Now with machine learning,
additional constructs
that are happening, you can get
to higher levels of accuracy.
So Google basically
says, we have
elements of machine learning
in every product that we have.
That's great.
That's Google.
But the majority of customers
out there, they're not Google.
So you have to be
very careful when
it comes to machine
learning, and say,
am I addressing the
right set of questions?
Am I having the
right to use cases
as part of machine learning?
And is it the right
thing for me to do
as part of the organization?
And if you look at
transforming data into actions,
Google provides different
type of concerns
when it comes from data
ingestion all the way down
to advanced analytics, and
machine learning, and abilities
to do that.
And these type of steps
would be required.
If you attended the Miles
Ward session, the first thing
that we do in
machine learning, I
have to get the data into GCP.
Somewhere, I need
to get the data,
and then submitting
applications.
And that generates
additional data.
Then you start applying
machine learning.
So these are key.
And that's part of the ecosystem
that Google provides in order
to give you that ability to
ingest the data, all the way
up to creating that advanced
analytics and intelligence,
and apply machine
learning onto it.
And if you are interested
in what type of constructs
that you are looking
into, here's the diagram.
Again I wouldn't go
and talk to my customer
and say, here, look how
Google is great, and all that.
Because that basically
tells complexity.
So we want to be more
prescriptive as part
of the process, and figure
out what type of things
that we need to
do in order to get
to that level of complexity.
So if you were to get
the data into GCP,
here are some of the things
usually that we see as big data
reference architecture.
So typical components, these
are the typical suspects.
I have two types of workloads.
One could be potentially
streaming workload.
The other one is
a batch workload.
And the objective is to get
it somewhere into BigQuery
or Bigtable, or whatever it is.
And usually, we look
into it, and say,
for Pub/Sub type
of streaming, we
have a Cloud Pub/Sub that
we want to incorporate
as part of the architecture.
And then, I could
take that stream,
and let it feed
through data flow,
because I want to do
certain manipulations.
I could do certain enrichments
on it, whatever I want to do.
And then I can have a
resting place in BigQuery.
So that would be one
path to look into it.
You can take a batch load.
You can put that batch load in
Google Cloud Storage, the GCS
component.
And you can take
that batch load,
and say, I want to apply
certain enrichments on it
as part of the process.
And then for this
particular load,
the data could be more
appropriate for being stored
as part of Google Bigtable,
because I am very concerned
about latency, and
Bigtable gives you
that type of access to it.
Or you can say, I would like
to apply certain Dataproc type
of capabilities,
manipulations, and then store
the data in Cloud Bigtable.
You still have
the option, if you
wanted to store data
in cloud Dataproc,
you can use Dataproc HDFS
on SSD or persistent disks.
But that's not necessarily
a good approach,
because it's more expensive to
store that data in Dataproc.
The best practice is to
have the data stored in GCS,
and allow Dataproc to run
clusters that would, basically,
figure out what would
be the right destination
for that data.
So this is pretty much
the end-to-end way
of looking at a big data
reference architecture,
by allowing you to get a
streaming load, or a batch
workload, to get
the data into GCP.
And then you have,
on the far right end,
the ability for any type
of data for the data
exploration, machine learning
type of activities, analytics,
dashboards, whatever it is
that you can start looking
and applying on these
type of data sets
that you have stored
as part of BigQuery.
Now let's dissect that piece by
piece, and look at it, and say,
I have a streaming load.
I just want to get it
directly to BigQuery.
Can I do that?
The answer is yes, you can.
There's nothing that says you
can't, with the assumption
that you're not
manipulating the data.
We talked about that earlier.
So you can get the streaming
workload or a batch workload,
and put it directly
in for BigQuery.
And you can do
simple manipulations
on the bq command, and data
will get into BigQuery.
If you want to go and say,
I have a batch workload.
I would like to go and put that
into my Google Cloud Storage.
I would like to do
some type of enrichment
on that type of
workload, and then
I want to batch that
pipeline into BigQuery,
and that's also an option
that's available to you.
And then this one is, I
have an on-prem type of data
that I parked on prem
through an ETL job.
Now I need to move it--
it's a relational, so I need
to move to Cloud SQL, into GCP.
And then I take that
data from Cloud SQL,
and I can run it
through my data pipeline
again against the
cloud data flow,
do some additional
enrichments, joins,
or whatever it is that
you want to do with it,
and then feed it into BigQuery.
That's also a pattern
that we see out there.
Or you can have a fan-in-fan-out
type of multiple streaming type
of clients, that you
want to get the data.
And as part of
getting that data,
you want to do different type
of processing for that data.
And you have different
instances of BigQuery
where you have
Instance A of BigQuery
and instance B of BigQuery.
And you can have the
right job being streamed
to the right channel
that becomes the ending
resting place for BigQuery.
And you can have,
also, additional type
of manipulations, where
you can stream and compute
before you publish.
So I stream my data
from a financial type
of company or organization.
And as part of the process the
data, gets into Cloud Pub/Sub.
And then I do
certain manipulations
on the data, certain
enrichments, calculations.
And then I add additional
type of windowing,
or do time type of
series calculations.
And then I calculate certain
correlations, and then
feed that again to a
Cloud Pub/Sub, where
I have multiple subscribers,
where I'm trying to figure out
how the stock market
is going to do
or how certain stocks
are going to behave
under certain types of
situation or conditions.
And I can feed that
into a trading system
where there could be people
who are waiting or acting
on these type of intelligence.
Or I could feed that
back into BigQuery,
where I can apply certain
dashboarding analytics, machine
learning, whatever it
is that I want to do.
And I can start exploring
with Cloud Datalab as part
of the process.
So what this is
trying to show you,
the suspects that you have
seen, they're very common.
So we talk about Pub/Sub,
Dataflow, BigQuery, Bigtable,
and Datalab as part
of the top components
that are usually involved,
and GCS, obviously.
These are the
primary ones that are
involved as part of the process
of getting data into GCP.
And here's an example--
interesting.
So here's an example
where it basically
shows I have an existing data
lake that's installed on prem.
And as part of that process,
I have different type
of data sources.
And I need to feed that
data into Google type.
So I have different
type of constructs
that I want to incorporate.
So I have the GCS connector,
where basically, I
can push the data
directly to GCS,
because GCS is a
Hadoop-compliant type of file
storage system.
So using that GCS
connector, I can
use the push model, where I can
push the data directly to GCS,
or I can aggregate the data, do
some type of enrichment on it,
and I can use a partner--
happens to be Informatica or
anything, it doesn't matter.
And I can use that to
push the data to GCP.
And then I can feed that into
my pipeline of cloud data flow
or cloud data prep,
which also allows
you to do some
additional data profiling
as part of the process.
And then you can have the option
to move the data into Cleanse
Data as part of the storage.
And this is basically
ingesting into a data lake.
And as I mentioned earlier
as part of the data lake,
we try to avoid storing
stuff in Dataproc.
So the preferred method is to
use the cheaper storage of GCS.
And if your workload
happens to be more
appropriate for Bigtable, sure.
Why not?
You can do that.
And in many
instances, you'll see
that people will go against
BigQuery to store the data,
and use Dataproc-- ephemeral
clusters, basically--
to run certain jobs, and store
the data in the right trusting
location.
And you can apply
the visualization
on that as part of the process.
And this gets us into the
machine learning lifecycle.
So the machine
learning lifecycle--
you know if you
attended Miles Ward,
you probably have
seen this diagram.
I did not have it, and I
recreated it for this session,
so I'll give credit to that.
So this basically
defines the first thing
that you need to do as part
of any machine learning
is to look at the use cases.
And I alluded to that
earlier in the session.
That becomes a really
important type of factor
to make sure that you are
addressing the right ones,
and defining the success
criteria that you want to do.
Then we get into
data exploration.
Basically, I want to do
exploratory data analysis.
And you can use any type of
clustering type of mechanisms.
I'm trying to reduce
the amount of parameters
that I want to build
the model from.
And I can go ahead and
select what type of machine
learning algorithm, and I can
do, later, further feature
engineering, which
basically looks
into additional types of
criteria and selecting
the right parameters
for the right model.
And you build your
first iteration
of the machine learning model.
And you iterate
on that with kind
of building your minimum
viable type of model.
And once you do that, you
basically look at it and say,
are there things that
we can change or improve
as part of the process?
And then you start presenting
results that, yeah, you told us
that we can challenge
the current supply chain
model that you have
in order to give you
better accuracy and cheaper way
to get these data parts coming
to the US through different
vendors and routes.
And here's the model who
would allow us to do that.
So let's look at
these results, and see
if there is any value
to them, or if the older
model is a better type
of performing model.
And then you start
looking at and planning
for deployment in production.
And that's where you start
getting into interesting type
of setups--
so what type of production,
what type of clusters,
what type of data ingestion?
How busy are the
machines going to be?
Are they going to be
busy all the time?
Are you going to
stream the data?
Is it batch, et cetera?
Are you going to run
this at the same time
while other data is coming?
So all these are
type of questions.
And usually what we do,
we start with the POC--
a simple POC that doesn't
factor any of this into it.
And people think that
once they've done the POC,
a lot of the legwork
has been done.
And you get into
the previous path
that we talked about
with data lakes.
It's not.
There's a lot of
consideration that
needs to be taken from 7
through 10 to make sure
that we have the right
models, we monitor them, they,
are the right ones
the most efficient.
And sometimes there could
be some performance issues
that could arise in the future.
So what do you do about those?
You go and rebuild the model,
and you repeat the cycle.
So the whole process
is iterative.
And lots of complexities
in the details here.
It's not just building
a POC in six weeks,
and we're done with that.
And you've seen this,
probably, before if you've
been to many of the sessions.
You can use your own
pre-built, ready to use models.
There is no point for you to
go and create a model that
can go and recognize objects.
We're talking to
different companies
right now to build solutions
around these things.
I can look at satellite images.
I can look at third-party
data, weather data,
and look at natural language
processing, Translate API,
to come up with a solution
that would give them
a better score when it
comes to underwriting
processes for insurance.
So these are things that
you can put together
as part of the process.
You can build a model
that takes elements
of these types of factors,
and incorporate that
into a model that can give
you a better result than what
you may be having today.
And you can use your own
data to train these models.
You feel free to build your
own models using TensorFlow.
And feel free to upload
them to Google Cloud.
Let them run in the cloud,
and see what type of results
that you can get out of that,
and empower your business
to be the right business.
I have one minute left I want
to spend on this client example.
I talked mostly about what
this thing is all about.
But this is a customer.
The pattern that we're seeing--
they were running
Cloudera on-prem,
and spending a lot of money.
Really, that was the
primary driver for them.
They were basically spending
about $20K per month
on their Cloudera type of setup.
And they came to us and said, we
would like to move that to GCP.
So if you look at
the architecture,
this is what they
have as part of this.
So they have Cloudera running
on GCP in VMs type of formats.
And the solution was
basically to get them
to the right set up using
Dataproc and ephemeral
[INAUDIBLE],, and
using Google Cloud
Storage as part of the process.
The previous session I was
here in the last 10, 15
minutes, the gentleman was
citing different statistics
about moving the Hadoop
infrastructures into Dataproc.
He was citing 70% savings
on hardware, 80% or more
on software.
We saved this company
from $20,000 down
to $4,000 per month.
And its about 80% savings.
So I'm glad we have
the consistency
in these type of settings
as part of the savings
that you can get from
migrating these existing Hadoop
workloads from on-prem,
or using VMs on GCP.
Sometimes, people think I'm
using VM on GCP for Cloudera,
I'm still on the cloud.
No, you're not.
Well, you are, but it's not the
most efficient way to do it.
There are better ways to do it.
And this is one of those
things that you can
use as part of that process.
[MUSIC PLAYING]